okay so the Lazarus contract is amazing
this is a really really good story and
the funny thing about there's something
really probably doesn't need to be said
is that this is really kind of a homage
to the Judas contract I mean the Judas
contract ended with the Teen Titans
annual this story ends with a Teen
Titans annual there's a lot of different
things that go into it now in terms of
direct comparisons between the two
they're similar but they're not exact
the Judas contract was big for several
different reasons one of the first was
that it gave us the origin of
Deathstroke which was a huge villain for
the Teen Titans the second was that we
ended up learning that one of the
members Tara was actually a spy she been
inducted into the Teen Titans themselves
and she was a spy for Deathstroke
designed to basically infiltrate the
team gather information on the team and
then Lau Deathstroke to defeat them and
then it also introduced Joseph or
Jericho now this is different for a few
reasons because of the fact that one
Jericho has already been introduced
Jericho was already introduced in the
Deathstroke story we covered that in
volume one now a Deathstroke rebirth vol
2 there were a few major changes or
really things that led into this
particular story the most notable one
was that Deathstroke basically went
blind I mean it was really like this
great big huge you know what is it 12
through 18 this 7 issue storyline that
was about Deathstroke going blind but
there were a few other things here and
there we found out that at the time one
of the significant members of Joseph's
life was basically having an affair with
Deathstroke again kind of a homage to
the character of Terra it ultimately
resulted and the entire situation going
awry Jericho losing his mind sort of
going crazy attacking people and then
eventually it resulted in the injury of
his sister Rose which basically kind of
put her in a catatonic state when her
skull was cracked but again you know all
these things really sort of went into
the idea that everything that
Deathstroke touches just turns to ash
that his life is nothing more than just
death and destruction so wherever
Deathstroke goes destruction will not be
far behind and that's the basis behind
this story is basically Deathstroke
looking at his life and trying to find a
way or trying to see if it's possible
for him to fix it now of course the
route behind all of this is actually
given to us right off the bat and what
we end up doing is we actually pick up
in the early days of the Titans
themselves back when they were
essentially the Teen Titans and again
this is kind of cool because this is
when they went against Grant won against
ravager now he's been a very huge source
of contention and DC rebirth because all
we knew was that Grant was one of the
sons of death of Deathstroke and he died
somewhere along the line
I've had something to do with it we
didn't know what happened to him we
didn't know what events took place that
led to his death all we knew was that he
had died what we end up finding out here
is that he'd basically been contracted
by hive to take out the Teen Titans and
the issue with this is that in the midst
of this conflict it resulted in grant
dying but the funny thing about this is
that it's actually hives fault that
grant died the serum they gave him to
enhance his abilities you know again
this idea of giving people superpowers
which all really kind of came to a head
and the whole story about the return of
the fearsome five sort of Titans prelude
to to this story the Lazarus contract
that hive had given powers to grant and
because of that it basically sent his
body into overdrive and his heart
literally just shut down it couldn't
handle it anymore now the funny thing
about this is that Slade Wilson viewed
this as the direct fault of the team
Titans themselves and it effectively
upheld what was called a Lazarus
contract or upheld a contract of grant
which in turn would actually tie
directly into Dick Grayson himself and
we'll find out exactly how far deep that
goes but again this really deals with
the notion of the Titans you know kind
of in their regular thing fighting up
against some foes let me to significant
nothing important but in the middle of
this Wally West suddenly vanishes and
what we end up finding out is that Wally
West is being interrogated now the
important thing about this and the
reason why this is so so important is
because this is effectively a tentpole
story and what I mean by that is this is
a story that's designed to basically
kind of prop itself up so that people
can see it don't take more notice to it
than anything else and they'll focus
their attention on that which again will
give them very important information the
other reason why is tentpole programming
is because of the fact that it just
draws so much attention it's just as a
huge and well publicized event but the
significance of this and the reason why
it's so important is because again this
rehashes the state of Wally West the
question is asked by Slade Wilson what
you know what's your involvement with
the Teen Titans tell me about your team
yadda-yadda-yadda
you know how are you here why don't we
know who you are so on and so forth
Wally West basically again reveals what
we already knew that when Barry Allen
had basically screwed everything up with
flashpoint that this deal Wally West the
classic Wally was carried over into the
new 52 but remembered everything from
classic DC but he basically been kind of
cast away thrown into the Speed Force
basically made to disappear in a
space-time continuum kind of hidden away
by the villain abracadabra and it wasn't
until Barry Allen remember
whoo-hoo classic Wally West was the
classic Wally West was able to come back
into and basically reappear in the new
52 but he's one of these missing links
he's one of these characters that that
carries over from before the new 52 from
the classic DC Universe so again it's
just kind of reiterating to people who
this version of Wally West is what he is
about now the way that this works the
reason why this is cool is because as DC
sort of mingling it in with the story
you know had been written it the wrong
way had they done it the wrong way it
would have been like and he's just here
and it would have just felt forced in
and it would have really seemed out of
place but we don't get that feeling it
goes in with the story it makes sense
Slade Wilson says then that's why I
don't really know who you are that's why
I don't recognize you know what's going
on but I was right when I came to the
conclusion that if you are Wally West
and there's another Wally West coming
around then you are either not from this
dimension or you're somebody who was
artificially created or something weirds
going on you're not natural you're not
native to this particular universe so
again it's really kind of a cool
scenario because it shows us how smart
Deathstroke is but it also shows us the
lengths that Deathstroke is going to go
to what we end up having is this great
discussion between Wally and Deathstroke
and where Wally basically says look you
know it was not our intention to kill
Grant you blame us for this but grant
died at the hands of hive he died
because hive screwed up his body when
they injected in with that serum we
tried to save his life it's not our
fault but Slade Wilson is really just
like a grieving guy I mean will you lose
somebody close to you in some kind of a
dire situation it's very easy to lash
out it's very easy to get angry at the
world and rightfully so because it's
such a traumatic experience but with the
character of Slade that's his life he
never really says yeah I screw up here
it's always somebody else's fault it's
always that person's father that
person's fault when that person's fault
over there it's never his fault there's
always a convenient excuse for why he
never did anything wrong in the first
place so again at this point with you
know classic while they west vanishing
we end up picking up with the Titans I
here's the funny thing I'm recording
this right after I recorded the Titans
rebirth video that I did and I feel like
I kept referring to tempest as Aqualad
I don't know it's one of those weird
things I always think of him as Aqualad
that's how he got started that's how his
character was introduced you know just
because of the fact that I've literally
pored over computer for four hours
studying the history of his character I
always think of him as Aqualad I mean I
can't help it it's just how I'm first
introduced images the way it is but one
those funny things here but the fact
remains you know picking up with the
rest of the Titans the question is where
in the world is Wally West
what in the heck happened to them and so
what this does is it really kind of sets
the stage for this fast-acting attempt
to try to figure out what the heck
happened to Wally where he's at but at
the same time the Titans are also
dealing with their own problems in the
form of Damian Wayne and the Teen Titans
now Before we jump into that again we
focus back on Deathstroke and this is
again you know some of the some of the
genius of his character in the sense
that Deathstroke actually analyzes you
immediately looks at Wally West and
basically says look because of the power
that you have it allows you to tap into
the Speed Force you know as you call it
to tap into this extra dimensional
source of energy and allows you to time
travel and that's ultimately the goal of
Deathstroke to time travel now what his
motivation is we'll find out in due
course but again because of the fact
that classic Wally West basically
wouldn't abide to what it is a
Deathstroke one to do which was a
predictable outcome given the fact that
Deathstroke has been monitoring classic
Wally West for quite some time what we
end up finding out is a Deathstroke had
taken the new 52 Wally West as a back-up
plan now this is kind of a cool thing
because what this does is it builds on
the inherent flaw of the character of
new 52 Wally West remember new 52 Wally
West is young I mean he's young he's an
experienced he doesn't know about all
the different kinds of villains that are
out there and that's really the huge
difference between the two that's one of
the reasons why this segment of the
story is so important is because it
highlights the contrast between these
two characters the classic Wally West
had been you know the flash ever since
he was a little kid when he basically
gained his powers in the exact same way
that while they west gained his powers
and so over the course of being a
sidekick for Barry Allen you know he
came across all manner of villains some
of whom were pretty straightforward all
they want to do with rob banks others
were a lot more devious and a lot more
duplicitous eobard thawne is a perfect
example and so because of this he's well
versed in all the different kinds of
villains that are out there the new 52
Wally West is not and so because of this
what we end up finding out is that Slade
Wilson had actually hung out with the
new 52 Wally West for a little bit of
time making friends with him getting him
to reveal information that he wouldn't
normally reveal which ultimately led to
Slade Wilson basically kidnapping him
and bringing him to his base of
operations now of course the other half
of this is you know again the Teen
Titans you know the Teen Titans trying
to figure out what in the world is going
on and trying to locate Wally West there
really is a whole lot to see here it's
really just Damian Wayne essentially
saying look I put talking to
on all of youth in the same way that
Mara did kind of taking a play and
saying look I'm the one that came up
with this she copied it for me
yadda yadda yadda but again this is
designed to sell a little bit of
distrust among the Teen Titans
themselves because after all the
conflict that they've had so far in the
time where they kind of reveal their
deepest darkest secrets and so on what
the end up finding out is that Damian
Wayne secretly put tracking devices on
all of them which is just a huge breach
of trust because there are times you
know whether you know whether you're
being a superhero or a regular person
there are times when you just want your
superhuman Claude to shine through and
you just want to be alone like you just
want to leave you want to walk away you
want to go get some R&R but the fact
that Damian Wayne put tracking devices
on all of them again it's kind of a huge
breach of trust now it doesn't seem like
a big deal but this will actually be
very significant once we get towards the
end of this story the other half of this
is that Damian Wayne almost immediately
deduces that Deathstroke has some kind
of involvement in this just because of
the fact that we end up learning does
the tracking device that was put on KITT
flash was basically attached to Damian
Wayne himself which is you know again
kind of indicates the deaths are kind of
handedness or had done something had
basically meddled in things now with
regards to hip flash himself again I
guess they'll new 52 wally west what we
end up picking up here is with the idea
did he actually agrees with Slade
because slaves us down and says look I'm
not here to be a bad guy I'm not here to
take all your power and kill you my goal
is to use the power of the flash to go
back in time and save my son's life and
that's a pretty understandable
motivation if any parent had ever
experienced the loss of their child and
they were told hey you have this
opportunity to go back in time and
change or you know save your child's
life and sure it might screw up the
future and sure who knows what what
effects it might have on the timeline
would they do it they would do it in a
heartbeat they do it so fast it would
make your head spin they'd be gone
before you even had time to finish your
sentence it's their kid and so again
this is one of the greatest moments
about Deathstroke because it humanizes
it you know where he has this mask that
makes him look sinister and evil and
dark and twisted when that mask comes
off and he's a guy with an eyepatch and
says look I'm just here to try to save
my son's life and I will do whatever it
is that I need to do to make that happen
it's very easy for someone like nutrakey
to Wally West to kind of follow in line
because he has an experienced flashpoint
he hasn't experienced jumping around
through time and seeing the kind of
effects that it can have on people all
he knows is well you know I don't want
to become a bad guy because my dad
Daniel WestEd that became a villain
suffer him Neil the road that it's
to become a villain is a lot more narrow
than somebody like Wally West looking at
that road and saying the road to hell is
paved with good intentions you know
pardon my language but the other half of
this is it Damian Wayne effectively
confronts Dick Grayson of the reason why
is because Damian Wayne had basically
hacked into the Titans Tower and
broadcast a video signal directly to the
Titans themselves which appeared to be
some kind of a conversation that Dick
Grayson had with Deathstroke now again
we'll find out what that conversation is
here in a little while but we ultimately
pick up again with the Titans of the
Teen Titans kind of coming together and
trying to find Slade Wilson only for us
to realize that Slade had basically
siphoned off the power of the new 52
Wally West and made himself into the
flash now there is a huge difference
here this is something that I want to
point out there's a big difference here
between Slade Wilson as he exists now as
the flash and someone like kid flash or
Wally West or Barry Allen with classic
Wally West with new 52 Wally West with
Barry Allen's they are what we could
really call like organic Flash's meaning
they tap directly into the Speed Force
in order to be able to use their powers
Slade Wilson has effectively just imbued
a suit with the powers of the Speed
Force so it's almost like what Daniel
West did it's almost like he grabbed the
Speed Force or grab the powers of the
new 52 Wally West put it in a battery
pack attach it to himself and now he can
run as fast as the flash in the end the
the result is still the exact same and
he's just as capable and as formidable
as he ever was but he is effectively
able to run through time and use all the
same powers that any flash can normally
use now what we end up doing here is we
jump back into the past again and we
jump back really about a year after
Grant was killed at the beginning of his
story and we end up finding out there's
a meeting that takes place between Dick
Grayson when he was still robbing and
Deathstroke himself and this is really
kind of a cool scenario because what we
end up finding out here is a Deathstroke
initially approaches the Grayson and
basically says look I have a daughter
named Rose all right I did not know that
I had to solder before but I have her
now what I want is for her to not have
to live the life that I've lived if what
you do is you take her under your wing
and you teach her everything she needs
to know in order to become a
contributing member of society
you know never knowing about my
existence never knowing that I'm her
father never knowing that I'm a villain
then I'll invoke a Lazarus contract
again this is kind of like you know is
really kind of rooted in the concept of
Lazarus resurrected from the dead it's
basically saying look my son grant had a
got to kill you I took over that
contract for him what I'll do is I'll
basically bury that contract I can bring
it back at any point along the line I
can resurrect it just like Lazarus was
resurrected from the dead and so the
idea is that if Dick Grayson basically
takes any direction or really takes the
life of rose in any path that will
ultimately lead to her following in the
exact same footsteps as Slade Slade will
basically resurrect his contract that
was originally taken by Brandt and then
go after the Teen Titans
now again this is huge and the reason
why is because of the fact that this
introduces the motivation behind why it
is that Dick Grayson was involved with
rose in the first place why he trained
her why she had such a significant role
in his life that had never been fleshed
out before all we knew was that
Deathstroke had a daughter named Rose
and that she learned how to fight from
from de Grayson and that was really it
that's really all there was it wasn't a
whole lot there there was a little more
information but her backstory was very
cloak-and-dagger in a lot of ways when
it came to Deathstroke rebirth the other
half of this is that Dick Grayson agrees
just because of the fact that he knows
that if he says no Slade will kill him
right there on the spot Slade will go
after the rest of the Teen Titans and
kill them and then he'll just vanish
and the Justice League's will never find
him again don't never know where he went
they'll never know where he is he will
just disappear and if it came down to it
he would track every last one of them
down and kill them as well Deathstroke
is a one-man army and he could
definitely pull it off on his own and so
of course what we end up doing is we
find out this was the action of Dick
Grayson this was the conversation that
Damian Wayne had basically seen when he
tapped into the old monitoring devices
that Batman had put on Robin Robin was
out doing his own thing to make sure
that nobody was doing anything nefarious
and this is why Damian Wayne basically
says look you have a hand or you know
something about what's going on with
regards to Deathstroke in this whole
situation so again at this point we
transition over to Wally West yeah with
Wally West having gone after Slade
Wilson only to turn around and run away
when Slade Wilson said basically look
I'm the flash you're the flash I'm just
as fast as you are I'm a trained killer
you're just a regular guy and Wally West
basically just kind of turned tail and
ran off we end up picking up with
Jericho now again Jericho basically the
surviving son of Deathstroke is out of
rehab after his whole experience kind of
going crazy losing his mind you know
hurting Rose you know putting her in a
catatonic state so on and so forth
Jericho basically appears you know and
kind of dipole
the story of what it was that had
happened to grant you know really kind
of giving us this whole backstory this
whole set of events and what we end up
finding out here is that grant again
because of the fact that you know Slade
Wilson and his wife were fighting all
the time because they were arguing all
the time because grant and Joseph in a
lot of ways came from a broken home
grant had effectively run away again
this was something that we covered in
Deathstroke rebirth vol 1 in our first
video on Deathstroke rebirth what we
didn't know is what happened after that
and that's what we end up finding out
the slave basically challenged the son
and said look if you think you're a man
then be a man punch me like a man if you
really believe that you're a man you can
go out in the world and make it on your
own then go out in the world and make it
on your own otherwise shut up and come
back home and so ultimately grant
basically left you know grant had to
stand on his own two feet but what this
did is it led directly into grant
getting involved with hive now again
we'll learn a little bit more about that
here in a second he really just kind of
takes up with a couple of people and
then goes off and that's really about if
we don't find out exactly what happens
after that in this moment what we do end
up doing though is picking up with Slade
Wilson again you know traveling back
through time experiencing all these
moments and ultimately coming across
grant himself as he's operating under
the moniker of ravager now again this is
kind of cool because this is when we end
up getting this a little bit of a
backstory with Grant and what we end up
finding out is that when he had taken
off when he had left he had taken up
residence with a handful of people who
just partied all the time and you know
engaged in all different kinds of
nefarious activities and so on and so
forth but ultimately got mixed up in hi
and hi again it's basically an
organization that exists in this kind of
world domination scenario by artificial
evolution by basically giving people
powers deciding who gets abilities who
doesn't again one of these kind of
groups that operates in the background
but has its hands in everything this
eventually led to the Titans being
enemies of hive led to grant being
rechristened as ravager would enhance
speed and durability and strength and so
on and so forth going after the Titans
and in the middle of this led to his
death now of course with Slade Wilson
encountering his son what we end up
finding out is that he's encountered him
two separate times before but the hatred
that grant has for Slade is so extreme
that he refuses to accept that Slade is
here to help him even when Slade says
I'm from the future I'm here to keep you
from making these mistakes this is not
the life that I wanted you to have Grant
doesn't care grant hates his father now
this gives us some pretty deep insight
into the nature of grant into his
character in the sense the grant is
basically trying to be better than his
other and trying to prove that he's not
his father at the same time so it's not
like he's just some kid who's being
violent not like he's some kid that's
just acting up you know he's basically
saying look you know my dad was a
terrible guy I'm better than him I'm
more capable than him
I can go out into the world I can carve
my own little path I don't have to be
him but again and he's easily
overpowered by Slade in the process kind
of continues again but ultimately it
just is kind of revealed to us that
Slade is just unsuccessful he can never
rescue his son he can never turn grant
away from the path of becoming Ravager
and so what we end up doing here is we
actually pick up with the attempts of
the Titans and the Teen Titans to kind
of jump back into the past and see if
they can't find where it is that Slade
has gone to and basically chase them
throughout the timestream now of course
this is basically the Titans making this
decision but it brings them directly in
conflict with their younger selves and
so really this is the modern-day Titans
in the Teen Titans running into the
Titans back when they were Teen Titans
it's really kind of confusing but it's
basically modern-day Dick Grayson
meeting as younger self it's modern-day
Donna Troy meeting her younger self now
this could potentially have massive
ramifications on the timestream your
reason being because of the fact that if
any one of them gets hurt or injured it
could forever irrevocably change things
and screw everything up and what we end
up finding out here is Damian Wayne
basically deduces that the power of
Deathstroke is the combined power of the
new 52 Wally West as well as some of
what classic Wally West has and so what
he basically does is he punches the
classic Wally West in the chest kind of
kills them for a few seconds and so what
this does is it modifies the timestream
and just enough of a short amount of
time you know a couple seconds or a
minute or two long enough that the
actions of Deathstroke effectively get
disturbed in a sense the Deathstroke is
just not able to save its son it kind of
has this cascading effect and so on and
so forth and so it's like Deathstroke
gets everywhere just too late
Deathstroke isn't able to save his son
as effectively as he needs to or isn't
able to save them at all and so again
well it's a little a little ambiguous
what this basically does is it allows DC
to come back and offer these small
changes to the timestream basically
saying well you know if Wally West was
injured for a couple seconds so the
classic Wally West was injured when he
was younger for a couple seconds then it
means he didn't get to a particular
place when he was supposed to it was
really kind of this kind of book and you
know adaptation in the sense that if you
left your house at 8 a.m. this morning 8
o'clock in the morning and you went to
work and you got there at 8
and who got a promotion you know your
boss came in and said hey let's have a
conversation let's talk to you about
getting a promotion what would have
happened if you left your house at 8:30
and you've gotten to work at 9:30 and
your boss came by your desk and you
weren't there and you missed the chance
for a conversation to get a promotion
that's basically what's happening here
it's a cascade effect younger Wally West
is attacked by the older version of
Damian Wayne which leads to the younger
version of Wally West impacting his
older self which sets in motion a series
of events that will ultimately you know
impact a DC universe in any number of
wings and so it's open and as it leaves
these changes open into for DC to come
back and say well this is different now
you know and that's different now and
this is different in this scenario is
different someone so forth and it can
all just kind of chalk it up to that
moment when Damian Wayne punched the
younger version of Wally West so again
what does does is it basically has the
slade wilson kind of jumping back to the
modern day sort of outrage of the fact
that you can never save his son's life
the grant willson is dead yet again so
the Cutlass it's kind of leads to a
massive conflict between the two groups
but it ultimately has Deathstroke
basically taking off yet again once he's
actually tied into the Speed Force and
trying to find a way to get back trying
to find a way to save his son grant yet
again but what is up happening is that
as crazy as this is and as confusing as
it can be a little bit we end up having
really this sort of telepathic chain
that's created in a sense that with the
telepathic abilities of all men combined
with the sort of psychic empathic
abilities of Raven what it does is it
allows the minds of a multitude of the
members of the Titans and the Teen
Titans to go into the Speed Force
because remember aside from the flash
they can't really go in there physically
a few people can but on the whole nobody
else really can if they did they
probably wouldn't be able to get out not
only that you know with the new 52 Wally
West chasing after him with all these
guys sort of in there it's a chance to
basically go in to grab Slade Wilson
dragged him out of the Speed Force and
bring him back to the modern day now the
reason why this is so important is
because with Slade Wilson momentarily
being an organic flash that is to say
momentarily being able to actually tap
into the Speed Force when he's in the
Speed Force as intelligent as he is he
would learn how to navigate it and the
Speed Force would stop being just this
enigmatic source of energy and he would
basically turn into a hallway of doors
and all those doors represent different
moments in time or different dimensions
so maybe Slade Wilson comes to the
realization that he can't rescue grant
but what he can
we can go back in time with his Speed
Force powers and he can kill the Teen
Titans before they ever become the
Titans or before they ever become
superheroes it allows him to effectively
become the Teen Titans very own version
of eobard thawne now that's the threat
that they face and that's one of the
reasons why they have to grab him and
bring him out the other idea Slade
Wilson basically becoming a
reverse-flash is a terrifying idea as a
terrifying prospect and so in light of
this with Deathstroke having effectively
been defeated quote/unquote by the
Titans themselves being beat by the the
combined forces of the Titans of the
Teen Titans being made to accept the
fact that his son grant is gone and he
can never be resurrected in any form of
fashion Slade basically walks away from
the mantle of Deathstroke he essentially
just quits he calls it a day and so what
we do is we get a couple follow-up
moments to this because again this goes
through the Titans the Teen Titans and
Deathstroke and so what we end up
finding out is that where the Teen
Titans themselves because the fact that
the new 52 Wally West had allied himself
with Deathstroke because he revealed so
much information to Deathstroke about
the Teen Titans Damian Wayne kicks him
out boots him directly out of the team
at the same time because of the punch
that Damian Wayne had issued to the
younger version of the classic Wally
West his future self still feels the
effects of this punch and so the result
is that if he continues running as the
flash his heart will effectively quit
meaning he really just can't be the
flash again he can't be a superhero
anymore as the one he does in this
really amazing moment this sort of last
split-second moment as he just kind of
races off knowing that if he goes for
too long it'll end up killing it so the
idea here is that the classic Wally West
may not be able to be the flash anymore
or if he is he's living on borrowed time
that he may end up dying now of course
this will probably result in him coming
back or something along those lines we
don't really know what road this will
take but again it basically sets the
stage for a lot of future changes with
regards to the Titans and the Teen
Titans as well as Deathstroke in terms
of what happens in the events that are
leading up to the introduction of the
Watchmen and all that kind of crazy
storytelling stuff but anyway guys if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys have a sub button to
become part of the robb Corp you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]